For this video, I’m going to show you a
faster, safer, and more convenient way,
to cut your apples.
To start, turn your apples upside down. You
can see the tops have a lot more surface area
than the bottoms, so by putting them face
down, they’ll be a lot more stable when
you cut them. Meaning less chance you cut
yourself, instead.
Next, rather than cutting an apple into quarters,
like you were probably taught to do, imagine
a “tic-tac-toe” pattern with the center
of the grid lining up with the middle of the apple.
Cut along these imaginary lines, holding the
pieces together firmly at the top as you do,
and just like that, your fruit snack is completely
sliced and ready to eat. The cool thing about
this method is that by keeping the pieces
together, it’ll actually stay good, for
a surprising amount of time.
I opened this one 3 hours later, and you can
see it’s still in really great shape, and
ready to be eaten. So think about this. The
next time you’re packing a lunch, try snapping
a rubber band around the outside, and you’ll
have a healthy snack, ready to go in an instant.
The best part is, you don’t even need an
extra baggie.
Now if you’re serving your apple snacks
at home, here’s a cool little trick to try
with the corner pieces. Cut 3 diagonal slits
across the apple slice in one direction, then
spin it around, and cut 3 more slits the same
way, so they meet near the bottom. With a
flick of your fingers, you can offset the
pieces, to make a fun, and decorative way,
to serve healthy snacks in a way that everyone
will love.
Of course, if you want to take your apple
artwork to the next level, you can easily
cut and rearrange one single apple, into an
edible apple swan. Look for how to make this in another project video.
Now just for fun, I decided to compare apples
to apples, with 3 different methods, to see
the difference in how they brown over time.
The pieces at the back are completely untreated,
and will be left out so they’re exposed
to the air. But I sliced these other two apples
“tic-tac-toe style” and bound them together
with rubber bands to protect them. The only
difference between these two, is that the
one on the left, is treated with lemon juice.
Some people say that the citric acid, in lemon
juice, will prevent your apples from oxidizing,
and turning brown. So let’s find out whether
or not that’s true.
8-1/2 hours later, let’s take a look and
see whats happened to them.
It looks like all the slices exposed to the
air did turn brown after all, and don’t
look nearly as appetizing. But by keeping
the slices held together with a rubber band,
the apple on the right only browned just a
little. And for sitting out nearly 9 hours,
it still looks impressively edible.
If we peek inside at the one spritzed with
lemon juice, you can see it looks just as
fresh as the minute it was cut it, and still
tastes just as good as well.
Now for one last experiment, I set up a time
trial to see which method of cutting the apples
really is faster. And just for your convenience,
I will speed it up a little.
Amazingly, you can see all 8 slices, are cut
in only 10 seconds. And there’s very little
mess to clean up at all. On the other hand,
it’s nearly 5 times longer with the traditional
technique, and there are chunks of apple core
everywhere.
Well now you now know a faster, safer and
more convenient way to cut your apples. That
will not only save you time, but won’t leave
much of a mess for you to clean up later.
That’s it for now. If you like this video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com